your entire kitchen is going to smell
like italy what up guys my name is kevin
curry the founder of fit man cook and
today in the tasty kitchen we are
whipping up a delicious creamy
mediterranean chicken and tomato dish
that's also keto friendly you are going
to love it first thing we're going to do
is season up the chicken thighs even
though this recipe is going to be
swimming in creamy sauce you still want
to add a little bit of sea salt and
pepper to the thighs
after that we're going to sear them in
the pan for about three to four minutes
get a nice deep rich sear in there and
it also helps to flavor the oil in the
pan
what i also want people to know is just
how easy it is to customize these
recipes you can swap out the chicken
thighs for some chicken breasts or maybe
even some shrimp you can swap out the
heavy cream for some light coconut milk
you can swap out the cauliflower rice
with some orzo or some brown rice and
here is my favorite step blooming the
herbs so we're going to toss in some
garlic and some aromatic herbs so after
the spices have been blooming for about
two to three minutes and it's super
fragrant then we're gonna reduce the
heat just a little bit and pour in some
chicken stock
we're gonna reduce this down and then
here is the banger add in some sun-dried
tomatoes and ooh
i'm telling you the flavors begin to
come together after that we're going to
add in some heavy cream
gently stir it and really monitor the
heat here when you have the heat too
high then first off you're going to
evaporate all of the creamy goodness and
when it's too low it's not going to melt
together properly this dish you can get
in and out of the kitchen in less than
30 minutes it complements so many
different eating styles i got started
because i was trying to save my own diet
and then i knew that i had to take my
health into my own hands and so i went
and i just began to read every single
book they had about nutrition and then i
taught myself how to get into the
kitchen to cook myself up something
calorie conscious and i was able to
transform my entire life by cooking
healthy food
once it simmers for about one to two
minutes then add in the goodness yes i'm
talking about cheese because everybody
loves cheese you're going to continue
stirring until you don't see any more
visible pieces of grated parmesan and
then we're going to nestle the chicken
thighs back into the creamy sauce then
take a spoon and drizzle some of the
sauce on top of the chicken thighs and
then add that entire skillet to the oven
to bake for 15 minutes
and after 15 minutes take it out of the
oven and then finish it off with some
fresh parsley so we're gonna steam up
some cauliflower rice and then put those
chicken thighs right on top along with
that creamy sauce and enjoy this
goodness
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
you